[Music]  [Music]  yeah oh  it's right there  most people don't think about heat as a  killer and it is  and we know that the numbers are fairly  high certainly  the event we've seen we're going to see  excess deaths a lot more than we should  have  because all of those deaths could have  been prevented so we have to raise that  awareness  [Music]  so  the world has heard about litton british  columbia which burns  almost essentially to the ground and  there's been multiple fatalities  reported there and other people not  accounted for  some people are having to go two to  three hours away just to get uh check in  with emergency social services  uh so this is something that we've never  seen before in this province or  really in this country anywhere  which way are we gonna go i want to get  stuck here